[Music]  you have no idea what's coming  mr. wit broke the rules  I trust you understand the repercussions  if he survives you shouldn't be here  nice suit good to see you too I need  your help after this we are less than  even  there's no escape for you the high table  wants your life  would you help set the move for our new  guest let us begin  [Music]  our services still off-limits to me what  do you need  guns lots of guns you think you can take  John with you got a nasty surprise  coming  I've been looking forward to meeting you  long time  and so far you haven't disappointed  we can keep this up as long as you'd  like  but this only ends one way  [Music]  all of this for what because of a puppy  wasn't just a puppy  you  you